check aroni mr. scumbag yes how are you
sir good man thanks for doing this I had
to be here how are you I'm chilling man
I'm chilling working on music all the
time
you know sanneh trying to stay positive
trying to stay inspired you know I'm
saying life of the artist man his life
good for the big baby scumbag right now
oh yeah man oh yeah bro like I got a
lizard like three months ago I'm like a
desert man Blue Tongue skink so uh these
lizards come from Australia I know they
come from Australia Indonesia and these
are lizards you can't just like get from
a Petco or like a pet supermarket so I
had the way and so there was a reptile
convention in Tampa back in a February
and ever since then I've just been on
dad duty like proud dad man I was I was
watching him just like run across his
cage up and down like earlier today and
I'm just like damn and like I love this
dude that's my boy my boy would you just
do it all gasp no brakes video oh man
yeah so we linked up Andrews down here I
don't know how long he's gonna be down
here for he might be here for like a
couple weeks or so mm-hmm but uh man
andrew is the dude man so what's crazy
is like a fan has sent me a video
I dare share they had shared a video of
him on Instagram when he went to
Talladega this is back in I seen that
video back in like December and I was
like yo what is this this is the
craziest [ __ ] I've ever seen in the
video that a has sent me he was
understand at Talladega and while he was
talking some dude that came up to him
and was like number three baby [ __ ]
Dale and I was like yo I gotta put this
on a new project
so I DM to Andrew and I was like yo like
is it cool if I put this on my project
he was like yeah man and I was like all
right bet and then come to find out we
had a lot of mutual friends like he's
cool with a lot of people and the
underground scene like
all the guys from GBC black Kray we just
have a bunch of mutual friends so like
when we clicked up he was like oh yeah
you know so-and-so oh you know yeah yeah
you know I'm saying so it was very is
very authentic man shouts our Andrew
Callahan and we definitely gonna do it
all gasps no brakes video like a like a
featured I gotta be a featured guest
there son we'll figure it out yeah what
what is he doing he's just like going to
like weird conventions and film itself
yes so what he does is like he you know
he he's like a journalist you know I'm
saying yeah he just travels around you
know I'm saying any type of current
events that there is around America he
basically covers it like when a y'all
remember when to a li the whole alien
[ __ ] was going on and like people were
camping out at area 51 here went he went
to Reno Nevada and [ __ ] he was
interviewing people that were like
camping out at the [ __ ] area 51 he's
been like crazy like crazy like
religious like cult conventions and like
he did the furry convention he did the
fairy convinced oh yeah he's been in
like protests he's been to Talladega
that one knows my favorite one that was
my far the best there's this so there's
this there's this big like there's this
big land it's like probably like an hour
and a half from here and it's called a
sausage castle yeah yeah yes so he had
went to the sausage cast
he's been going back and forth from here
to Tampa I mean from Tampa to the
sausage Castle you know I'm saying so
he's out there you know getting new
content and [ __ ] like that yeah now that
everything's opening back up he's able
to hit the road yeah yeah yeah great
before everything shut down he's like
really starting to blow up
yeah dude cuz bro like last time I
checked he had like one point something
million I think he was like yeah that's
insane when I found out about him he was
like under like five hundred thousand
they didn't Tim and Eric's production
company just reach out to him about
doing some stuff you know what he uh he
was he was telling me about that he was
telling me about a TV deal so yeah rate
to TV
like what I like about Andrew like he
slowed down the herbro like he's so he's
so it's so authentic like very genuine
what you see on all gasp no brakes like
that's how I love the suit yeah yes
really like neutralizes him in any group
so he can like just blend in anywhere no
matter how extreme it is somebody
yelling about buttholes there's somebody
in a furry costume humping him he's just
still there with the microphone the
microphon dude yeah bro I love his air
maxes to he he's so faithful to the air
maxes I looked at his footwork I was
like oh this shoe is identical to the
Michael Jordan suit that he wore in the
90s yeah big ass suit yeah there's huge
pants yeah as part of this it's part of
the look of its iconic
yeah nice like he he can't ever like
being some regular clothes like they're
gonna be like the [ __ ] dude that's
how he blends in just take the suit off
and then you just like neutralizes
himself he's in the group again I told
him I wanted to get him in a music video
and I don't know doing what I think I
think will do like a little skit scene
like in the middle of the video where
like it's like pretend I'm like
pretending on all gasps no brakes yeah
saying some type of some type of cameo
Easter Egg for the video you know yeah
hilarious yeah it'll be so crazy how
long you been in Tampa are you
originally from here yeah man born and
raised man born and raised Florida oh
gee yeah have you always been a bucks
fan yeah dude my dad my dad is a
die-hard bucks fan bro my dad is like
what when lose or draw you know care bro
like I remember when so I remember he
was telling me when the when the Bucs
fighters came out my you know like the
first three seasons like the orange the
original bugs the creamsicle yeah back
in the 70s they lost every single game
like three seasons straight my dad was
still going hard for him back did so you
know saying it's uh I feel like I feel
like now like the tables are gonna turn
a little bit and like a lot of people
are gonna hop on the bandwagon
we got Brady yeah for show like I'm not
sold really know why I'm not sold I mean
this is like the same thing when Brett
Farve went to the Vikings
I feel like Brady still got some fuel
mmm come bring that ring I would love to
see it happen
I've got no denying that it could happen
we got grown I'm skeptical we got grown
- yeah crock though he's brittle he's
old he's those old bones I ain't gonna
lie they're gonna have to like they're
gonna have to just bench Gronk and tell
the playoffs when they make the playoffs
and then just set him loose during the
playoffs because he's always getting
hurt you know he saved the Patriots he
was always hurt yeah that's true man
amen I got it I got to go to a Bucs game
and hopefully like this quarantine [ __ ]
like isn't like bad you know I'm saying
come like August September cuz I got a
good last time I went to a Bucs game was
like I was like 13 14 you know I'm
saying and that's back when I was
actually playing football like my dad
would take me to the Bucs games cuz he
was working for the Tampa Tribune
so like anybody that worked for the
Tampa Tribune they would have like they
would be given like free like VIP passes
so we would be like and like we would be
we're like the general managers and [ __ ]
would be we would be in the [ __ ] the
the like the see-through glass the
bottom again right right right they
cater it and everything got the food and
then hey yeah not bro it was so VIP I
was like it was every Sunday so yeah man
shouts out Tampa Tribune man they they
treated their employees really good you
gonna do a song about Tom Brady it's
already recorded it's already recorded
it's it's waiting we get a sneak peek
honestly I don't I don't like it
enough right now I got to rerecord it
and that's how that's how it is what a
lot of my songs man it could be the
slightest thing and I'm like oh and then
my engineer though my engineer would be
like oh you're overthinking it like no
sir but it's just it's just the life of
a perfection and I'm trying to get I'm
trying to get better at you know not
overthinking [ __ ] because a lot of times
it is just oh like nobody's worried
about that like literally if a fan was
to listen to a song they wouldn't catch
what I'm so no yeah sometimes just gotta
let go just gotta let go of it and just
move on to the next one and a lot of the
you know really good [ __ ] is the most
authentic and and that becomes the best
show so you know once you ramp up that
output and you just kind of let go of
the process you can really start to
discover who you are as an artist yeah
and you just get out of your way and
whatever comes out yeah yeah like when I
first started I was so self-conscious
about [ __ ] like I was like like if
you're not taking no risk Matthew or if
you're worried about what somebody think
of much like it it's it's good as dead
man you can't you can't you can't can't
worry about that [ __ ] man and Pablo
Pablo was stressed out a lot they're
like [ __ ] it like who are you doing this
for you or somebody else right you know
I'm saying and at the end of the day
that's what it is man and that's a I
actually had a thought too because I
grew up like playing guitar and playing
in punk bands and they coming up through
Tampa I like really curious about what
it's like being a rapper like going
through the DIY scene and like what it's
like to just learn how to rap and
actually be good at that like how do you
how do you do that honestly it's a gift
bro it's a get like it's a gift but at
the same time it is like practice like
you know for me I felt like I was a
natural for show cuz really like when my
homies introduced me to rappin I wasn't
even rapping at the time they was like
my homies skinny actually I know him
from since middle school Louis come back
to and that's where that's where the
name scumbag came from we was all in a
group homies from back in middle school
so my homey was like yo I'm starting
this rap group I want you to be in it I
don't even matter bro like just be in it
to be cool you know since I was like ooh
you know not knowing not knowing [ __ ] so
I hopped in the studio for the first
time and I was a I was a
natural doing and I mean I just stuck
with it I stuck with it and you know it
worked out like what really worked for
me is just getting the reassurance like
even if I say this all the time but I'm
like yo all of that old should I made
was so trash but they was gassing me up
you don't said so I feel like what fuel
my [ __ ] was just the confidence that
they gave me like yo this [ __ ] is fire
like it's crazy I was like for real you
know says yeah man that like that being
fueled just those those good compliments
and you know combination of that and
just me believing in myself like it you
know it it made me want to get better
you know so it's not as it is a gift but
at the same time anybody can just you
know just with anything like basketball
sports like learning the instrument you
know whatever you you can get better at
it
[Laughter]